hi everyone welcome back to plays of the
week brought to you by ochoto tv
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
let me get let me spam down four or two
on your ass let me just kill you already
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
fight
they're all perfect
okay
uh
[Music]
perfect
perfect
[Music]
oh
[Music]
did you get it
uh
[Music]
uh
what
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
great
up
[Music]
send in your clips by following these
steps before you submit your clips make
sure the quality of the video is clear
put your ign as a file name for your
video
limit submissions to three to five clips
a week per category
don't spam submissions and don't send
folders with your clips on avoid
full-length matches or just cut the clip
you want on the desired play until the
end of the round
next send your clips via dropbox in the
correct category you can always find it
on the description of every other tv
series
once you upload your video file if it
prompts you to give your name just put
in your ign
also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay match
please understand that it may take some
time for some clips to be featured
because of the review process
thanks for watching don't forget to hit
like and be sure to subscribe for more
tekken content
[Music]
you